“No one has ever done that, no one has ever
done that in the history of Dota.”
What sort of play could possibly have caused
such a reaction?
What sort of play could be worthy of such
praise?
It was bold.
It was innovative.
It was completely and utterly insane.
This is No Tidehunter’s Roshan Bait from
DreamHack Winter 2012.
It’s the Grand Finals of DreamHack Winter
2012. An unsponsored local team, No Tidehunter
were up against the American powerhouse, Evil
Geniuses.
Against all odds, No Tidehunter not only topped
their group, but made it all the way to the
grand finals without dropping a single map.
(Casting)
Led by seasoned veterans Loda and Akke, the
team was mostly made up of inexperienced players,
fielding the likes of s4, AdmiralBulldog and
EternalEnVy.
In true David vs. Goliath fashion, their opponent,
Evil Geniuses, were a titan of the Dota scene
that featured establish stars like Maelk,
DeMoN and Fear.
Fear: "The competition this year, it's really insane actually because, the way I see it, no one that I know of can predict the win."
On paper, No Tidehunter shouldn’t have given
EG too much trouble, and Game 1 seemed to
follow that script.
After EG lost their group stage match against
the new squad, they seemed to have figured
out the Swedes’ playstyle, making short
work of them in the rematch.
(Casting)
Following their decisive 35 minute win, Evil
Geniuses appeared poised to take the title
and shut the door on No Tidehunter’s underdog
story.
The Swedes needed to come up with something
to shift the momentum back into their favor
and they needed it soon.
After all, necessity is the mother of all
invention, but no one could have expected
what came next.
(Casting)
With TobiWan’s now legendary words echoing
through the venue, No Tidehunter pulled off
what is now known as “the Roshan Bait,”
rocketing them to an early lead and sending
the crowd to their feet.
To this day, that play is still one of the
most clever and most unique plays in Dota’s
lengthy history.
S4: "To start off we were trying to do a level one Rosh but then we came up with better ideas as it went on."
Using AdmiralBulldog’s intentional suicide
as bait, NTH convinced EG that they were attempting
to do a sneaky Level 1 Rosh.
S4: "We played the Grand Finals, not on the main stage Game 1.
And then Game 2 we had to go onto the main stage but we had a 30 minute break.
So, it's like, what are we going to do guys? We're down one game
we're playing against EG.
So we just came up with a strat to get some momentum, you know, get into the game"
With two early kills under their belts
and EG’s momentum waned, The Roshan Bait
put NTH in prime position to reclaim control
of the series and they made sure to jump on
the opportunity.
Hoisting the trophy high above their heads,
No Tidehunter secured their place in Dota
history by not only winning the title at a
Major event despite not having a sponsor,
but for doing so while pulling off one of
the most creative and effective tricks in
esports history.
While new, inventive strategies are continually
pushing the boundaries, few can match this one.
NTH had the audacity to pull-off the bait
in the grand finals against a veteran team
and their execution was flawless.
(Casting)
It might have happened really early in Dota 2's history
but the Roshan Bait still stands
as one of the game’s most memorable moments.
Time has passed, other plays have come and
gone, but something about the Roshan Bait
has caused it to remain.
(Casting)
Maybe it's Tobiwan's perfect call.
Maybe it's the underdogs pulling off an unlikely victory against a perennial powerhouse.
Or maybe it’s that, for one incredible moment,
No Tidehunter proved that the only
limit to what is possible is your creativity.
(Casting)